Android patterns for performance
For mobile apps,
Serial data is a large and consistent set of information
Which you should bring from your servers.
But you were learning
That the order of the data inside the serial form
May greatly affect its output size?
My name is Colt McCannless.
When it comes to serial data,
It may be important to get rid of your standards for organisms
For something more effective.
Most individuals organize their data in memory
As objects filled with numbers, functions and all other things.
A sequence of arrays of these objects preserves their structure
In the resulting data stream.
This type of organization
Is what we call a series of structural models
Or a group of objects or categories, name it.
The conclusion is that the sequence is sequential
Reflects vector-oriented data layout within memory,
It is useful in terms of software,
But eventually leads to the amplification of the serial flow.
First, consider that in the sequential model,
Each member's value must be publicly declared in its own name.
Which means that with every example of your category,
Each property will have the full name of the property
And the value declared in the serial file.
So it's clear that your files will be larger
Resulting in all existing extra attribute names.
Second, you need to understand that this is the worst possible layout of data
To apply pressure to your file.
Consider using GZIP compression; it is standard for most HTTP responses.
GZIP presses data by searching for duplicate strings in your file,
As long as it is separated by a framework of 32 thousand characters.
So as you grow your class,
Different types of data are similar to each other,
Which means there is less repetition within that window of 32 thousand characters
Thus reducing the pressure less.
In general, the use of an array of model structures
To create larger sequential files do not really press it properly.
What is the solution?
Struct-of-Arrays model.
Think of the Struct-of-Arrays
As a position substitution in your data.
If we assume that we have a list of objects, choose from them what is similar to the property
Of each element, and then insert them together into their own array.
So pay it with every property in the category.
For example, create an example of the width values
And an independent figure for height values.
This serial result results from simple arrays of similar data type.
For sequencing,
This pattern returns some immediate benefits.
It first removes extra attribute names
Of the sequence.
They are all folded into one example.
So you'll basically create smaller serial files.
Second, similar data types are now consistent,
Which means that the GZIP algorithm
It will be a better chance to discover duplicate matches,
They will be closer now and will be found
It is more likely to be present in the 32,000-character frame.
Thirdly, data regulation helps in this model
To separate the content of different types of pressure.
If you have, for example, a row consisting of a thousand numbers,
GZIP may not be able to do much with that information.
But it is best for you to apply Delta compression
On this stream of numbers before placing it in the sequential file.
This is something you can not really do
In a structural array model
Because of the complexities of vector-oriented design of the objects embedded here.
Please note that when you change your data,
You can get better compression and faster sequence
Through the use of binary sequence architecture
Such as Protobuffs, Nanobuffs, or FlatBuffers.
It produces much smaller files than JSON or XML.
In the end this is what you want, right?
I mean wonderful layers that you can stack on top of each other
To create the most homogeneous applications.
Check the remaining Android Performance Patterns videos.
Do not miss joining the Google+ community
For other insights from other great developers.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.